[Music]
Tim have you got any drunken stupid
purchases ye probably all right I like
hanging out with my friend when he's
drunk because he buys everything for me
and I feel like a gold digger
oh yes yes you know what happened one
time okay so I was at a club right in LA
and my boy conceded from wildin out like
whenever we get together we always um we
always buy bottles at the club and [ __ ]
right so we were like yeah we're we're
late but it was like we'll split it
because everyone's in town five hundred
each on the bottle and then like that's
expensive
what's a bottle - I don't even remember
right yeah honestly it's a little silly
right so we really go so like we spend
five hundred each like regular [ __ ] he
doesn't even drink right so I wake up
the next day I don't remember what
happened the next day he's like yo he's
texted me he's like what made you feel
like you were French Montana last night
to buy three bottles of ace of spades
spades is the [ __ ] gold bottle of
champagne so I checked my [ __ ] I was
like what are you talking about I
checked my I checked my account 3000 out
of my remember I didn't remember [ __ ]
yeah
yeah because I guess I was just like
yeah like yeah let's go another bottle
of champagne let's go mondo what a sweet
drunk and not financially response so
glad that you're not a data entry
specialist I've had a whole month's
salary for you but I can I wrote it off
as as uh annex like an event for my
three G's about the hall why do you ask
well I asked because this uh this guy
here he had a drunken night and so he
asked his girlfriend who was not drunk
and with at home to buy some dominoes he
was heading home and he was like and so
apparently the girlfriend had a hard
time ordering it through the app and so
apparently she had tried six times so
then this guy as he's on his way home he
was like don't worry I guess he's drunk
on his way home well I don't know how he
got home but he's on his way home a
little bird things bird scooters yeah
you could drive oh you're funny you
can't of course I never really don't
want you to yeah I want you to but you
can well you can't drive a car to you
shouldn't
yeah that's a good point yeah anyway
sorry what were you saying Joe can you
drive one one one do I have to even ask
this question I did one one good burn
you know what happened I panicked oh
that was not my original clip anyway so
this guy here his name is Willie and he
has his girlfriend Hannah right
so Lee and Hannah so Lee ends up getting
home he goes upstairs he knocks the [ __ ]
out because he was that drunk he didn't
[ __ ] the pizza he didn't [ __ ] the pizza
oh but he woke up a Domino's franchise
sorry there like a boss I'm gonna be a
little late to work he's like [ __ ]
lucky what are they saying
anyway yeah work is here and he shows up
and it's a dominoes that you won't stop
oh that's well we did do a similar story
a while back where this couple was so
drunk and they ended up buying the whole
hotel that they were saying oh yeah
it was like a bed-and-breakfast in like
okay that's better yeah like Thailand
anyway so expensive like whatever
yeah yeah we're out a tired man
hey we got a hotel but anyways so then
this story here so she ends up enter the
door because the pizza guy gets there
and there are 20 pizza's pizzas 15 bucks
of size 50 bucks just sides
yeah chicken wings he ordered 15 boxes
of chicken wings and they were 14 piece
chicken wings
damn this guy's tight Wow but you know
what though I think the Pizza Hut
chicken wings are better yeah main
street [ __ ] and it's crispy yeah it's
battered first Pizza acquired wing
Street and they up there [ __ ] Wings
game like go along how do you guys know
this [ __ ] we're talking about geo
everyone knows this [ __ ] if you have you
ever been fat before you don't know it's
in the UK they use whatsapp out there I
use whatsapp with my UK friends yeah
yeah
I have international friends came out to
177 pounds British pounds Oh so look at
all this order it was one meeting it was
one medium Domino people too though like
there's times where I've entered the
same order multiple times not Domino
specifically but a restaurant and then
they'll call me like hey is this correct
I'm like ah should have [ __ ] up these
people are like [ __ ] this guy dude yeah
they thought that they were during a
party so they show up and then the guy
like they canceled our barbecue order in
Austin because they thought it was a
prank
really he did this for his chick though
right his chicks like Gill bring home
Domino he wanted diamond well he's lucky
that he's not so [ __ ] boozy that he
wanted Cheesecake Factory because if
that happened to me I'd faked my own
death 15 orders of Cheesecake Factory
that's probably like [ __ ] $3,500 or
some [ __ ] so when the postman showed up
to your door what do you do I'm like
that guy's dead I don't live here
he doesn't live here I don't know that
guy yeah you did but you can eat
cheesecake for like the rest of the year
right side you could freeze it I
wouldn't get that though cuz I'm more
I'll get the ABS Oh what are your
favorite apps oh my god girl are you
kidding me what are the tell me what are
those egg rolls and she's hotter ones
yeah they're so good that like the
[ __ ] what do you call it - the
tartare oh I don't like that Mommy no I
don't like that I like that
welcome Olli what's that one no nacho no
I don't like that lot of chocolates
what the [ __ ] do you like oh that's what
Nikki likes well what do you like what
do you like to know what about guys I
only know what happened on him all he
wouldn't his legs wouldn't Nikki likes
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's Mary don't
you guys know that when he's at home and
Nikki's not there just waiting I sit in
the dark he's like Nikki make me some
brownies out of avocado she can yeah
honestly I have no identity without her
really like no life at all
oh yeah like you wouldn't be like a
parasail or some [ __ ]
but you bet you've been working out
without her that's your thing right
gonna work out thirsty that's my thing I
thought that was because you want to
look good for her that's pretty true his
whole life is motivated by Nikki and
that's okay Howard bye Nikki it's
nothing wrong with that Howard fine
thank you appreciate why it's normal if
you're married right we actually just
have a very serious talk about this
stuff because why was she like
so here [ __ ] [ __ ] tagging them are
like a little puppy and have your own
life no so so basically it was like this
so
I have been helping Nicki keep the
kitchen and everything clean since the
new year cuz well I always do that but
since Ania were like no matter what
there are no nights where we leave
dishes out like we [ __ ] go hard on
the [ __ ] so I've been going hard
unlike making sure that I clean all that
[ __ ] up then my own personal space in my
office is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show because
you spoke us so much on the catcher
focus I'm making like the Nikki space is
cool and so even when Nikki leaves town
when I surprise her I clean all the
nikki spaces up I just [ __ ] about your
space who cares what take care of more
of this few spaces that's all so like my
own body which I let go a couple years
ago and I've been fighting to get back
now I wasn't thinking of myself I was
thinking about my woman too much too
much so instead of the night you got to
go to put yourself in on the score meat
first you got to be on the score so
badass you get a pot you guys as they
say on American Airlines you got to put
on the mess before you help that's all
the airlines yeah no they don't say
never you know do you even know how to
read okay to be honest I go to sleep
before they say any of those safety
precautions but I feel like all the
airlines say help yourself
you know before you go that's not sure
virgin you know what they say they say
if you want to [ __ ] in the bathrooms ask
the flight attendants if you want no
that's not virgin [ __ ] yeah of course I
love this I hate that
yeah but wait you know you wanna sing
American Airlines is the only airline
that says what are y'all talking about
why this is the I know about me I can't
be a troll I'll give it to someone jobs
like random I like to be like bless you
for it
but what is it cringy for you is that
cringey it's hard to keep up yeah I'd
like to know it's like are you guys come
out of it I would've done that to
different to ten for ten you but do you
feel like all honey is that that mother
it's like I trust I would always be like
guys just get it like right here and be
getting too many too many hens but I
don't know what if you're causing damage
by letting them know that's not enabling
that's being a decent human being for
all you need to let people work for
their work you let people work for their
food yeah
Tim's now gonna go out into the wild and
he's not gonna know what to do because
you've been given them yeah we give them
conditional manolio that all airlines
see I've been yelling all the other
airlines like guys please help yourself
first before you help your baby I don't
know some crazy guys yell I put on my a
my soundproof headphones
American Airlines there Tim we were
talking about drunken [ __ ] these wings
okay buffalo buffalo Wow II like the
more than wing stop um a shot of the
Buffalo Wild Wings shot the wing somehow
you tried wing chicks though wing chicks
you tried wing chick this is new [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] good right yeah I gotta I
gotta take you wing chicks is [ __ ]
good have you had big Wang's big Wang's
I love big one
what's big wings it's a buffalo what's
never been to buffalo wings what they're
very very Tim big Wang's is one spot
there's a change but I was just trying
to make it simple for him because you
know I just want to waste people's time
but I'm sorry if I hurt your feelings
I'm upset I don't like the buffalo wings
that if they don't batter first and make
it crispy I like I like those because
when they make it all soggy I'm not mmm
so you'd like big man so I'm trying to
say you make a big wing it is it crispy
yes they're perfect
the textures perfect sauce is perfect
but it doesn't beat wing chicks no it
does you know why I know that because I
went to big wings for like 10 years and
so I have a personal attachment to this
estate never been to lean chicks
I know chicks wings are [ __ ] Hugh I'm
personally invested in the crunchy
understand her personally invested in
wing chicks I'm emotionally involved
I'm actually involved delicious do you
guys know how emotions work yeah just
like Nikki I don't care if there's a
hotter cooler chick out there I pick
Nikki already so I'm emotionally
invested
so I already picked big wings so your
wing chicks thing good for you [ __ ]
y'all did you're never gonna have any
Steve yeah I want some actually we have
a picture of you now uninvited your band
dude I gotta go this weekend oh wait I
can't
[Music]